hallo ihr lieben nahe steht ja auch so
auf schokolade ich persönlich bin so ein
richtiger schoko fans könnt ihr jeden
tag eine ganze tafel verdrücken was ich
natürlich nicht aber ich könnte
und deswegen zeigen sich heute meine
schokolade chste schokotorte überhaupt
die ultimative torte ist das und ich bin
mir sicher wenn ihre schoko fans seid
dann werdet ihr diese torte liebe mein
schoko boden der auch ultra saftig ist
den habe ich euch in einem separaten
video gezeigt weil das so eine art
grundrezept ist von mir und das verleger
ich euch hier in der infobox den habe
ich bereits zubereitet und
durchgeschnitten der ist hier hinter mir
schon bereits abgekühlt und jetzt zeige
ich euch die weiteren zutaten für das
frosting und was wir sonst auch
benötigen für das frostigen und
gleichzeitig wird es auch die creme sein
benötigen wir kommentiere ich habe hier
zart bitter genommen ihr könnt auch voll
mich nehmen außerdem bacau puderzucker
mascarpone schmand oder creme fraiche
und zimmer warme butter
desweiteren benötigen wir chocolate
chance und etwas milch die milch und die
chocolate chance benötigen wir erst
später jetzt bereite ich hier das
frosting zu oder creme ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher wie es nennen soll denn das
ist eine universell einsetzbare creme
als füllung als frosting zum spritzen
ihr werdet gleich sehen die ist so toll
und ich habe jetzt hier peter kuvertüre
genommen wichtig ist dass sie einmal
schmerzhaft dass in der mikrowelle
gemacht jetzt einfach und dann 20 bis 30
minuten lang abkühlen die geht auch
nicht fest sie ist immer noch total
flüssig aber es ist wichtig dass die
abkühlt damit uns die creme gleich nicht
gerinnt und ich gebe jetzt in meine
küchenmaschine zuallererst die weiche
butter zusammen mit der ouvertüre und
lass das alles einmal schön vermissen
[Musik]
auf niedriger stufe habe ich dass es
miteinander verrührt ungefähr eineinhalb
minuten und jetzt sieben jetzt erst die
trockenen zutaten rein also bei kakao
und puderzucker anschließend noch
mascarpone schmandt rhein alles gut als
miteinander verrühren und dann ist auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
so jetzt ist die masse ziemlich fest
aber das wird alles noch aufgelockert
durch unsere mascarpone und den stand
dem jedoch dazu geben und es
funktioniert besser wenn das ganze auf
zimmertemperatur ist
[Musik]
so die creme ist fertig erstmal auch
langsamer stufe ein bisschen verrühren
lassen und später könnt ihr immer höher
gehen dann wird richtig schön auch die
luft rein gespann die erhalt ist eine
richtig schöne fluchtwege cremen noch
ein kleiner tipp falls ihr kleine
klümpchen drin haben solltet weil
irgendwie mascarpone und schmand nicht
zimmertemperatur hatten oder ein
bisschen kälter waren und die schokolade
sich damit verbindet schlag einfach
immer weiter das problem löst sich dann
einfach wie von alleine und ihr werdet
merken dass die klümpchen auch
verschwinden so ich bereitet alles vor
und dann zeige ich euch für die torte
befüllen
nun habe ich mir alles bereit gelegt
einmal eine tortenplatte auch der wir
unsere torte servieren möchten dann habe
ich noch einen bug day ist optional es
geht auch ohne aber so ist ein bisschen
einfach und ordentlicher und unsere
creme die musste vorher nicht kühlen die
kühlt erst später ich nehme mir jetzt in
unserem leckeren schoko boden einmal das
oberste stück reeders um damit für das
ungerade stück schon mal weg haben und
dann fange ich an zu schichten
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt die schokoladencreme
darauf gebe gebe ich es noch ein
bisschen milch auf den boni er ist schon
saftig genug aber mehr ist mehr und
deswegen gebe ich noch ein bisschen
milch nein es geht auch zb kakao
irgendeine sirup der nie mit milch
vermischt alles was sie möchte
[Musik]
meine torte ist komplett gefüllt die
oberste schicht also den deckel da gebe
ich nur noch ein bisschen krems
verstreicht ihr das denn genauso wie die
seiten und den schritt mache ich jetzt
schon dass ich in vernetzten backing
werden die seiten einstreichen und dann
können wir die torte
ich kann so bevor einstreichen meine ein
streich technik also zentimeter raul ist
ja ja und so kann ich direkt gucken
sobald ihr dann zufrieden seid die torte
rundherum verstrichen habt geben wir
schon mal ein bisschen dekor auf die
torte und solange die wir noch weich ist
dennoch weiter nicht in schwung und ist
nicht fest gewonnen gehen wir hier
unsere chocolate chance dazu ich habe
jetzt längst halbiert und wird sie am
unteren rand der torte befestigen
[Musik]
so der rand der torte ist jetzt fertig
jetzt gebe ich sie für eine stunde in
den kühlschrank denkt dann je länger es
ihr sie ein kühlschrank tod ist so
fester wird die creme also zwei stunden
reichen ist kein problem gerne auch am
vortag oder vor arm denn mit am nächsten
tag richtig schön fest und ich habe auch
von der creme noch einiges übrig für das
frosting also dass ich später noch mal
was drauf spritze ich sagte er es ist
creme für lungen- und frost gingen in
einem und deswegen liebe ich diese
kämpft und wir sehen uns gleich wieder
zur restlichen dekoration nach dem
kühler des die krebs schon etwas fester
geworden und ich plötzlich keine rosen
auch dafür habe ich eine große sterne
genommen in meinen spritzbeutel gefühlt
und jetzt wird sie nur noch dekoriert
[Musik]
und fertig ist unsere absolut saftige
und schokolade die torte
mein persönlicher favorit weil ihr wisst
ja ich bin absoluter schoko fans und
falls ihr es auch seit er macht sie
unbedingt nach natürlich könnt ihr auch
variieren die zwischen schichte
schokolade eurer wahl geben süßigkeiten
aber auch früchte ist auch ein toller
ausgleich aber ich denke immer wenn
schokolade dann so richtig die genauen
mengenangaben stehen hier unten in der
infobox ich freue mich sehr auf eure
fotos mit dem hashtag in sketchen auf
instagram abonniert meinen kanal auf
youtube und aktiviert die glocke ein
paar passt ja auch nichts mehr bekommt
immer eine benachrichtigung und ich
freue mich über einen dämlichen nach
oben und 1 kommentar wenn euch das video
gefallen hat bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
churchill okay jetzt
während die kamera gucken
ja hab ich vor des fotos nicht gut
geworden ich habe ein video gemacht
ok probiere für uns haben sich
machen.foto warum ist diese stadt
erst mal ehrlich wie möglich buchen
aber der berner ist und der kunde sehr
gibt es mehr weißraum weiß warum ich
jetzt hören würde